brothers and sisters
you guys have probably already seen this
heard about it Andrew take coming to
Islam alhamdulillah we made a few
reactions but we wanted to address a few
more things this is why I'm Muslim any
Christian who believes in good and
understands the true battle against evil
must convert and then he quotes the
Quran so be patient indeed the promise
of Allah is truth if you guys want to
see us discuss this with Andrew Tate
then comment Andrew Tate in the comment
section below and we will try and get
him on the podcast today they got drag
queens that are trying to be preachers
in in churches world they're allowing
this they're promoting this the state
taxpayer money is going into this bro
and I don't know man like what do you
guys think about that it's okay bro it's
a big time today aside from being gay
bro it's just like who like what has you
know Andrew Tate said this in in one of
the videos he's like if you're tolerant
to everything you stand for nothing and
he said this is a non-muslim bro and I'm
just like now that he's challenging
Christians that are generally trying to
like enjoy good and come to the truth to
come to Islam I think that's powerful
bro because at the end of the day it was
the end of times the Christians that are
genuinely sincere will be tried
accordingly versus the Christians that
are like they know that Islam is the
truth they know that Jesus isn't God's
but they're too arrogant to admit
otherwise there's questions that we have
right
and when you start looking for these
questions as a Christian
you don't find the answers you actually
shunned away and kind of uh demonize for
even asking these questions
but in Islam you're encouraged no you're
actually told
to seek and you told the question you
told to look for the answers
like if you aren't doing that if you're
just blindly following it like you're
doing something wrong
and like as a when when I was into the
whole Christianity thing because
that was a big deterior that's a big
thing that just threw me off completely
and I think there's a lot of things well
not a lot of things but I think there's
a lot of uh Christians out there who
have the same thing but they push it to
the side because
um they try to emotionally justify
some reason to stay within the religion
you know what I'm saying or they try to
justify some random reasons even if it's
not emotional like you know Andrew take
before he became Muslim he was saying
that he was a Orthodox Christian because
of the the
people they had the context that he had
they were powerful in the churches and
stuff like that you know like
even then
even then bro like after he let that go
like look who he is now alhamdulillah
and I mean you can see a clear agenda
with these people you can see a very
clear agenda and a lot of the time
people's actions speak so when an
organization or government does certain
things a lot of the time those actions
speak now Imagine One Day the government
turned around they're like we're gonna
Implement you know everyone's gonna be
like wow the government's Muslim all of
a sudden did they all convert so same
thing when people you know start
implementing these things like your tax
dollars you're going to go to this and
that and it's not something you agree
with or something you very clearly
disagree with you're going to look at
that government be like well they have a
very specific agenda and when you look
at the roots of these countries you'll
find that they they formed based on
secular principles which is the division
of a church and state or the division of
religion and state now some places are a
little more secular some places are a
little more lenient with religion and
people practicing their religion but
there is no secular state that actually
really allows a religion to fully be
practiced like Islam for example they
don't let us have our you know Sharia
courts they don't let us have our laws
our legislation none of that stuff and
this is a pact we made with the
non-muslims living in their land so it's
fine it's not a problem but they
basically end up falling into hypocrisy
because now what they're doing is and
they're forced to do this based on their
secular principles they're basically
forced to assert certain things they
know are against religion because
they're in favor of liberalism like this
they're people who have very clear moral
views against it but they are allowing
children to be prescribed pills and have
surgery done at children surgery done on
them and when the father steps in to say
I don't want this he gets fined he has
to pay a fine
sometimes even imprisonment bro yeah
where's the freedom of religion and that
if he's saying this for religious
reasons where's the freedom of religion
and that
we went into this with the with uh
brother Paul from blogging theology on
an episode talking about Christianity
and inshallah if you guys missed that
make sure you check that out
yeah
inshallah I mean you wanna you wanna let
him know
yes Bismillah
[ __ ]